two and a half years ago we found dr.
John Calhoun knee-deep in mice in the
mouse heaven he designed for the
National Institute of Mental Health
Animal Center near Washington dr.
Calhoun wanted to find out what would
happen to a mouse colony given
everything mice need except living space
the result was chilling two and a half
years ago more than 2,000 mice were
packed into Mouse city today a tiny
handful of survivors Huddle's in one
corner of the city dr. Calhoun explains
what the overcrowding did to Mouse
city's inhabitants the last thousand
animals falling never learned to develop
the social behaviors they never learned
to be aggressive which is necessary in
defense of homesite they never learned
to court there was no mating being no
mating there were no progeny and the
older animals whose behavior is already
becoming disrupted they eventually
reached to that age too old to reproduce
and so it was all left up to these last
thousand or so when we call the
beautiful ones because not engaging in
any stressful activity and only paying
attention to themselves they groomed
themselves well so they look very fine
specimen but from that point on which
was about the time that you were here
two and a half years ago this
reproduction totally ceased and the
animals have just aged and died at least
one human group the eat tribe discovered
in Africa by dr. :
Turnbull has gone through a similar
terrible process according to dr.
Calhoun the two conditions that they
went through was that there was a
decision on the then colonial government
to make a wildlife preserve of this big
Valley which was their home with their
hunter-gatherers
moved up onto the mountainside and
gathered together in much higher
densities that have been spread out
small groups all placed in one place and
also required to engage entirely
different way of life which their social
roles the whole everything they learned
how to do had no means under those
conditions the social behavior broke
down tireless and began living is that
they still live together but their
activities was just directed towards
themselves everything you would think
it's human disappeared perhaps the most
chilling conclusion from his mouth city
studies says dr. Calhoun is that once
this change in social behavior occurs it
apparently cannot be reversed is this
fact fact of apparent irreversible phase
shifts that get some of us a particular
concern over the fate of the human
situation because we see worldwide the
breaking down of social role the
increase in contact of the result of the
breakdown of social roles and because
there are too many people if this might
lead to an overriding of our control of
our total culture would be set into a
process which would either fix us
rigidly forever into some sort of global
tribalism without any adaptation to
change or they would result to have
eventually some declined very much like
we've seen here but that postponed
something dr. John B Calhoun with a very
sobering look at a possible future for
us bill Roberts from the National
Institute of Mental Health animal center
near Washington
dr. Calhoun why do we have to make
decisions now on our population control
well the populations are very
interesting one is one of talked about a
population explosion well there's no
population explosion at least not quite
yet it never has been
or they say he's always been a
population explosion if we go back to
about 40,000 years ago there were
perhaps four and a half million people
on earth it had been none many fewer
than this for previous 2 million years
of man's evolution and then suddenly the
numbers began to increase and perhaps a
little crude drawing here will show this
these are in millions now this is 110
100 million 1 billion and then we go up
above here and if we take a time scale
here inverse law we go back to a hundred
thousand years ago and we go back to
make this then to 10,000 years ago to
1000 years ago yeah 1,000 years ago then
a hundred which is 1/10 to 1 year from
sometime in the future so these are
entire in thousands of years and if we
we look at population growth in this way
starting back about 40,000 years ago
population starting at about here is
gone roughly along this direction now
this is a rather complex curve it's of
unforced occur but simply said starting
here at 40,000 years ago it took about
20,000 years this back for about 20,000
years for the population to double then
the next doubling
about 10,000 years then each doubling
5,000 years to the next EE 2500 and so
on
what doubling our win now doctor we're
in in the tenth doubling in the eleventh
doubling is that which with the final
one
well pretty near it might be the final
doubling starting shortly after the next
here grew up in here scale about right
if which the five world population might
be of the order of Florida it's four and
a half billion now people would require
only twenty years to double so starting
from 20,000 years for the first doubling
up to about twenty years if this
historical process continues no so that
we're back here a little ways from that
not very far in the next century can if
we mathematically projected dr. on a
calendar year perhaps when the
population reaches the point where it
outstrips our natural resources our
power supplies well our food supply when
you say mathematically this is what
forger did projecting this age-old trend
not aged over 40,000 years rather short
time if this trend continued you would
have instantaneous doubling
well we know that's impossible and
that's the critical question is that
something is going to happen that man
will be different from the start of man
and this is where a man started about
40,000 years ago as a cultural animal
not as a biological animal he went
considerably back in time below that but
at beginning this new process where the
quote now was the only animal who could
really control his numbers that is to
keep enlarging them which is increasing
its own potentiality by so doing and
this is continued until now we hit a
critical point here where this process
can't continue and so from this time
forty thousand years ago to early
the next century defines weak old man in
man ends at this point whether there are
a lot of bodies around he's going to
have to be something quite different
from what he has been historically and
so one thing that he could do that he
was certainly capable of doing he just
keep reproducing so that's one choice
and another choice that we have Arlen
which will have to be in effect by early
in the next century is that he can
stabilize the population one can keep
going
not very much long nine billion I
haven't quite gotten my figures here to
double to the nine billion but if this
is the end point if we if the number of
children for adults continues as it's
been in the past there would be about
nine billion people at this point if we
begin slowing down so that the
population can stabilize which is the
ecological model as we try to do for
wildlife management to maintain a stable
population then with fewer children we
might keep the at this level really we
have seven and a half day now the
critical point here is how many adults
there's ideally they should be at this
upper optimum three and a half billion
adults in order to make most effective
the network of people communicating with
people however if we go on a third
there's a third choice and this is the
population will begin slowly to decline
and if we go towards that goal we would
have at that point I'm roughly about six
point three billion total people with
less than considerably less than two
children a family doctor what do you
think now the stress on environmental
problem
was trying to solve them should
government to the politicians being paid
more attention to this problem you think
they're all interlaced it isn't that
simple but that well the problem the
environment is just one one problem
which we're focused on now and this may
be a real trap because we only look at
the physical biological aspects of our
surroundings where if we focused instead
on what is much more sensual
comprehensive problem and this is
evolution and the designing of evolution
and in fact we like to say that we are
revolutionists here but a particularly
the kind of revolutionist but you've now
spell therefore Glee now we all know
what the symbol is it says prescription
but so we're concerned with prescription
for evolution of the design of the
future the design of evolution so we're
revolutionist well doctor why are we
falling into a trap paying so much
attention to environment well we are in
an environmental crisis there's no
question about it the concern of the
government in this question is good the
even greater concern particularly the
college level and the environmental
teachings are underway during April of
this year are extremely good movements
but they may be a very deadly trap for
this reason that is if we can focus just
on the good environment the biological
environment the physical environment we
will miss a great deal of what man is or
could be with a concern for increasing
human potentiality and again we like to
say we'd like to put mental the human
capacity back in
environmental this is what we're all
about
and we can set a trap to the trap we're
setting here is we're looking at the
environment on the strictly biological
model and not a man
future evolutionary directive model is
if we can develop a stable population in
which everything becomes fixed the
unchanging over time and now we'll be
back in a global tribal situation sure
we might survive for millions of years
but we are going anywhere
we like the lungfish in lake manyara
same situation they've handled it very
effectively whenever stress this come
along they encapsulate themselves on a
mud ball and wait out the dry period and
then come back for the environments back
in a suitable condition so we could
become lungfish and evolution would
essentially end what is government or
what should government be doing now it's
aware of this problem in your opinion
are we doing enough ah
we're doing very little at least I think
there's not it I don't think it's
necessarily level at the guard what I
think this is a whatever comment that
could be made here is one of general
awareness of becoming involved in the
design of evolution the prescription for
further evolution we have to have a long
time perspective both in the past and
the future and where we may go and that
of the issue the big crisis now is not
going to take of environment relating
the number of people it's not a number
of people it's people times capacities
of the average individual or the total
human capacity know if we we can choose
now the time for choosing a goal and
this part relates to numbers but it also
pertains to whether we're going to
school
what has been the definition of man for
the last 40,000 years some aspect of
this one of these is what we call human
potentiality the capacities of the
average individual to to understand
develop new insights to communicate with
his fellows more effectively if that is
a major overriding goal and is selected
and we select and one of the necessities
for that is maintaining a changing
environment which includes the numbers
and the only way to do that now is to
decrease numbers so that if we choose
the goal of gradually going into a
declining population with increasing
human potentiality
we're now at 1970 the critical point is
about 75 years from now but is
tremendous time lag and social change I
mean it's been only a very short time
since the Supreme Court ruling
pre-integration and we've made lots of
strides in some ways and very little in
others but this is a much much more
drastic change and if we're going to
change numbers towards a declining
population the whole attitude of
people's values the decisions have to be
made in a very short time we've got
let's say 15 years or to 1984 so in
essence if we we have about 15 years of
grace or opportunity that this crisis
presents to us for which we can change
our whole value system or not change the
value system but change the mechanism
for changing the value system it's of a
meta process if we don't do it within
this time we will probably be at night
we will go into 1984 toward Orwellian
science so this is why it's critical
it's the most part this time right now
is the most critical time since some
time before when man made this discovery
we'd probably took him about 15,000
years to learn how to discover and
kind of space a conceptual world of
ideas and progressive development of
ideas so that in the early primitive
hundred group and they had about 15,000
years to solve their impassive when they
were studied by the carrying capacity of
environment the physical environment
now we're also stuck a similar problem
and have about 15 years so it's a quite
a burden and the future of our future of
evolution depends on the next 15 years
it's the people here now who are
involved now which is critical and it's
the question of involvement I'm an
ecologist ecologist psychologist however
hybrid and it's a question of
environment with the equity of
involvement in the internal environment
of physical and social that is the
crucial question in our studies here
which we use mice and rats and other
animals for and that's where we bring
into the focus our our research is on a
question of involvement and they are bit
enough and the one who is bitten fails
to run away there's one type of and this
is one of the types of of lack of
involvement of Kotal withdrawal from the
reality of the environment but that's
compatible with that species
what 2,400 mice the order we don't know
exactly what it is now between 2200 and
2500 mice that his body is moving bodies
but they're really only about 150 mice
in here real mice that is mice who are
in the social swim all the others have
been rejected in one way or another
what's happened on this is it which
reproductive behavior is completely
inhibited it's inhibited the car
the leather it's inhibited because the
last few hundred maintained them as
juveniles and although they're now
adults they no longer get engage in
aggressive behavior or an reproductive
behavior and we call them the beautiful
ones because they're so excellent
physically they're unstressed I see one
down here most most of these live in the
apartment houses and rarely come out but
I see one who's taken temporary refuge
and when the nesting material supply
cans now go over and pull him out so you
can see what a beautiful specimen this
animal is but as far as the mouse is
concerned he's and nothing is that he's
a total nothing taken
now here he is lying in the going great
doctor
here he is lying in the can to place a
temporary retreat he's colored very few
practically no rooms he's in excellent
physical shape he has two or three necks
but compared to most of the animals he's
in excellent shape and these animals
from previous study shows that they are
unstressed they're just not here in so
far as he volunteered that you started
this experiment with just a few my some
20 months ago apparently you've been
able to dissect some have you noticed
any changes in tissue well the the major
thing yesterday the major thing well
certain classes of these for instance
comparing the males on the floor here
who are withdrawn they are highly
stressed animals but the stress comes
from each other because of this peculiar
violence that they exhibit which leaves
them as this animal with his tail all
chewed up but they do it to each other
these are highly stressed individuals on
the other hand the beautiful one which I
just showed you are very extremely
unstressed and Lebrun we've run the dart
at julius axelrod is run the in a stay
of the enzyme which converts
noradrenaline to adrenaline as the basis
for this on the other hand we've been
removing females and other populations
just terminated and looking at their
uteri
and for animals up to a year of age
we've come up in the latter history of
the colonies they're essentially no
evidence of a conceding believe there's
at this stage this is part of the over
living phenomenon and it's these
individuals who are not conceiving of
the ones which are not stressed they're
the beautiful ones and lack involved so
that's the
that the essential story of what's going
on in our studies have you been
surprised doctor about the results of
this what you've learned so far some
twenty months ago did you think all
these things were going to happen well I
had a slightly different hypothesis
which held true only in the early stages
and this was at the larger the space the
smaller the ultimate population density
that's proved not to be true but a
second aspect of that hypothesis was
that larger the space with reference the
number of colonizers the slower it would
get started and this has been true
because the essential analogy here is
that when there are few animals is in
this particular universe a male any
animal any Mouse when he was out would
rarely need another and therefore he
identified with all of his physical
environment so his own ego boundaries
extended out to include all of these
things which he was committed to and
therefore any other animal coming out
and moving towards any portion of that
would elicit anxiety and therefore
aggression and we have huge territories
and this is a sensual formulation of
territoriality so that in the larger the
space the more likely animals developed
territoriality and the more extreme and
this didn't give it initial reproductive
rate and so with a smaller we have
smaller universes than this and they
grew much faster it got started quicker
so that's another facet of this problem
that that gradually washed out beyond a
certain level and then the population
increased for a while
fairly rapidly and then it hit this
level at which animals began being
rejected out into public space as the
males living on the floor here the
females are rejected but they just don't
come out they stay back in the apartment
houses
laughter one final question here is a
human dr. Calhoun is a human being after
going through this experiment what goes
through your mind are you worried about
the future of mankind a pathological
situation like this gives us
understanding of what may be going on in
the human situation which might go on
and be catastrophic and what is really
catastrophic and where the real fear is
is on a level where the mice and man are
extremely similar it is the mice have
programs they're like little computers
and this is basically genetic with a
much smaller element of learn behavior
and too high
contact rate this organizes the program
so that it gets washed out so it's it's
disconnected or doesn't express itself
this way that the lack of involvement on
human level we do have a much more
complex brain it does get programmed
less by genetics less by redditor than
for the mice much more cultural but it's
just a subject of being disorganized
having a program disorganized through
inappropriate sequences of contacts too
many contacts and so that we have this
danger and part of the danger isn't that
we don't have an adequate establishment
not a we we're now saying because the
cold establishment doesn't provide all
appropriate channels we should destroy
the establishment we need federal
establishment to allow
interrelationships to protect us from
too many contacts but to allow us for
those contacts as we do it gage in to be
more meaningful for our own lives and
for meaningful to others in a
compassionate sense of each of us being
involved in helping the other to fulfill
his role will have
more rules and this is where the notion
of compassion comes in is helping each
of us helping others to fulfill their
programs for development and so we at
this peculiar stage where you're you are
highly optimistic same time highly
pessimistic and you wish to throw your
weight intellectual way to moving
towards the optimistic side to opening
up continuing evolution